[Music]
[Applause]
we'll get to more phone calls coming up
johnny avello is the director of
draftking sportsbook operations in other
words
he knows how to gamble
and uh what do you think about my pick
there johnny i got the chargers packers
in the super bowl
dan you were all over the place so i
don't know which one was actually your
pick no no it's chargers packers i had
to give you i had to give you my
reasoning for how i came to that
conclusion
i understand no
that's a that's a good pick uh you know
what you're you're staying away from
all the chalk uh which is usually a good
thing to do
uh you know you mentioned the bills you
know the bills have just
run across hard times for so many years
and so many things have gone wrong
uh they certainly have the talent to get
there but yeah you know tom brady won
the super bowl so many times and you
know it it wasn't always
uh because they were the better team
it's because they were fortunate and
that's the way i see it you have to be
fortunate
good luck has to come upon you to win
the super bowl okay but would you rather
go
like all the money is going towards
buffalo right now
right
correct yes that's correct buffalo is
our number one uh choice for to win the
superman and what's your pick
uh
i'm a bookmaker i'm not supposed to be
picking teams to win i'm just supposed
to be booking the action no seriously um
i
i bet buffalo in the past uh but i got
him at much better odds than five and a
half to one
so i i think buffalo is the team to beat
but that is such short odds you can't
you can't take that price at this time
during the season before we've even had
a snap
um there are some teams out there i
think you know longer shots that
you know could have you mentioned the
ravens i think that's one the eagles you
didn't mention
um you know the the unsophisticated and
specific sophisticated bettors uh both
are on that team
to win the uh nfce so
uh you know that could also be a pick
and you know the vikings if the packers
don't materialize they're always there's
always a chance there i wouldn't go much
further down the line though than the
patriots at 50 to one so that that
includes teams like the raiders the
cards the titans uh you know all those
teams have an outside shot is there a is
there a bengals
team this year that you see
i i i like the season last year can they
you know
do the similar thing uh you know only
lose games by your losses are three
points or less i don't know uh but is
there a team that will be this year's
bengals
uh that's a hunt well the bengals were
about 125 to one at one point last
season so who's gonna
let's go with our our las vegas raiders
uh they are not that type of price but
they are in that 40 45 to one range they
have the pieces i think it's up to derek
carr
and how involved are you with setting
the line
as a a bookmaker
um
we have a large team so i'm a consultant
for the team now uh you know so i don't
you know when
when i ran the bricks and mortars
locations in las vegas i only had a team
of seven guys so i pretty much primarily
had to do all the work but now that we
have a trading team of 75 plus wow uh we
rely on a lot of other guys
to do the work in various sports give me
the game that still haunts you as a
bookmaker in vegas
um that would be the
seattle new england game with uh seattle
on the one yard line
and we have a decision of a couple
million dollars to the plus for the
house
uh and we know that
we know seattle's winning that game
they're just giving the ball to lynch
and he's running it in it's the end of
the game they elect the pass and so
that's a turnaround of uh four million
dollars
what's it like when you lose a bet like
that in the room
uh when you look in the room the
if you have that type of decision then
the general public is on the opposite
side so they went absolutely nuts
because i was down in the room when that
happened oh um for the bookmaker it's if
you've been in the business long enough
it's let's move on uh we have another
not football game tomorrow but we have a
basketball game tomorrow so uh you know
we start a whole brand new season
bookmakers you just don't cry you just
move on
how much money is on the rams to repeat
uh they're not looking at the rams this
year um the rams are in the middle of
the pack so there's a lot of other teams
above the rams the
the bills are ahead of the rams the
bucks are headed to rams packers
um you know we already mentioned the
bills
uh
chargers so their charges are actually
one of the
picks that are in the top three
so uh you know they're not looking at
the rams repeating at least early in the
season but remember these futures are up
all season long will be adjusted they'll
be up even while the games are being
played
what's the best piece of advice you've
given better
uh stay within your limits
uh don't chase
you know have a game plan do this for
entertainment
i remember i'd bet college football and
if i lost then i would go i'd double up
on
the nfl on sunday and then i always had
monday night as a bailout and that's
what you mean by chasing where
you you know you cut your losses you
have to swallow your pride and then just
try to bet smart and we rarely do that
exactly how did you feel after you lost
that you know that double up bet you
didn't feel too good did you you know
what johnny i never enjoyed the win as
much as i hated the loss so when i won
it wasn't as big a deal when i lost that
that so the pain was was something that
always over would override the joy of
winning
yeah i know there is pain in losing but
that goes for anything doesn't it
uh why do you have a scale in the
background there of your room
that's an old scale dan that i picked up
at a antique store it was in pretty bad
shape when i got it and i uh you know
got it to where it's uh you know in good
shape now i don't need to weigh myself i
just thought it was
a nice old uh old-time looking scale i
thought it might have been from a
weigh-in at a vegas fight like holyfield
tyson or something well you all right
dan i'll tell you the truth it's it's
how i weigh the money that we win wow
[Laughter]
you might need one of those scales where
they weigh cattle you know or you can
put something a little heavier on there
johnny uh
have fun tonight and uh we appreciate
your time we uh thanks for joining us
thank you dan have a good day that's
johnny avello he is uh the director of
draftkings sportsbook operations
he runs the book there or at least helps
them run the book